Barry Allen
They call him the fastest man alive !
He is not !
Up is down
Black is white
Do not get distracted by anything you'll see along the way
What are we gonna see ?
It is the Reverse Flash
He is back
It is so much more fun to be bad
It's pretty missed up
Yeh, this is ground zero for pretty missed up
Hey Youtubers , it's Charlie
So,some extra presents just got delivered
The Flash drops some new footage
It's really like the same trailer with some extra scenes
and there is really two big things going on
there is some mirror master stuff  happening
and some Earth-2 stuff happeneing
if you didn't miss that last trailer video that i posted
there is a new round of the reverse flash ring give away is going on now too
it's all you have to do is to enter is to be a subscriber and leave a comment on this video
I've got a new arrow footage , new legends of tomorrow footage
so i'll announce the winner whenever i post those videos later
But the biggest thing to me in this trailer , like the big difference from the last teaser that they dropped
was that Jay Garrick is like : Don't get distracted , up is down , black is white
i think he is talking about the mirror universe
but you see like Grand Gustin walking into the Earth-2 police station
the mirror is even different too we'll talk about that in a second
But episode 10 , like the next episode whenever the Flash is comes back
it's supposed to be the mirror master episode , you know just based on the IMDb description
so i think that we are gonna see a version of the mirror universe
and then we also see the characters go to Earth-2
if not in episode 10 , in episode 11 or 12
Police station, Killer Frost, Iris West  all these in the trailer , all are Earth-2 stuff
but because the laws of physics are the same on Earth-2 ,i don't think that Jay Garrick voice over is talking about Earth-2 specifically
So let's talk about the mirror real quick in the police station
Because there is really elaborate set piece they built for season one of the Flash
It was super beautiful
and it is appeared that the justice league using the Greek Gods
But the Earth-2 mirror just a little bit different , it's like just the justice society version of that
If you never read the golden age or the silver age comics , just to explain Earth-2 just conspetionally
What happened is DC had all golden age chairs , Jay Garrick is the golden age Flash , Barry Allen is the silver age flash
so when DC wanted to revamp all its characters
in the silver age started by new Barry Allen he took over for Jay Garrick
What it did is , it took all the golden age characters and said they existed on Earth-2
So it was like all their adventures, all their lives everything they happened in those comics in the golden age comics was happening on Earth-2
So that's how DC choose to explain the Earth-1 justice league existing
along with justice society and then be able to do cross over issues where they both teamed up
But they don't show  the entire Earth-2 mirror , I am curious to see what is at the top here
But I can't wait to see the characters from Earth-1 go to Earth-2
that what haven't seen yet
Every time we've seen Earth-2 , it's been a flashback
It's been like a Harrison Wells flashback , or Jay Garrick flashback
There is like a whole history of all these Earth-2 characters, that I am sure they mapped out at least a little bit , at least  the biggest characters
Let me buy a pretty good idea what Harrison Wells backstory was before the season
But you know as they built out new comic book characters
, they have to fill their back story
Even if it is not something we get to see on TV
And I think part of the reason that we haven't got to Earth-2 yet; is that they wanna set up this core conflict with all the main characters on Earth-1
And then they donna want to give away too much what might be going on with Zoom
Because the more we learn about Earth-2 , the more we learn about the creation about Zoom
Just to be clear, I know there is ton of theories about who is Zoom could be
But remember, the way they pitch the accident at the particle accelerator explosion on Earth-2
, he was created just like Barry Allen was created
So someone from their present day
I think the Batty speech at the beginning of the season is really important
She basically tells Sand-demon to go and eat a ****
like you got powers because you were in the right place at the right time
So I think Zoom all about the idea of what happens if somebody else got
Stroke by the lightning instead of Barry , someone who happened to be in the right place at the right time
Speaking of Zoom I feel like him holding her up her is the best evidence that Batty is not Zoom ,like  just one more theory to cross of the list
But let me know , what you most excited about when the show comes back , I mean there is a lot of
legends of tomorrow stuff happening but just for the Flash specifically
Personally  I can't wait to see Killer-Frost
What I am prep to do next , legends of tomorrow or Arrow trailer next
Then I do Dr.Who charismas special video, and then whatever left over after that
And there is also cool Captain America civil war stuff probably do that on Sunday
So while you guys wait for everything to post
you can click her to watch the Dead-pool Red Band trailer again so awesome , it's such a great trailer
And you can click her for my latest Star wars Easter eggs video
Thank you so much  for watching everybody let's high five and I see you guys tonight
-English Caption-
-Omar Ahmed-